[Music]
welcome to simulation today we're gonna
be talking about atmospheric science
energy and we're sitting down with mark
Jacobson who is the director of the
environmental science and energy program
at Sanford and a professor there as well
thank you for coming on the show well
thank you for having me on the show
really appreciate it yeah
and so I mean your work is super
important to talk about because there's
no way to sustain on earth without
figuring this out right yeah the
problems of global warming air pollution
mortality and energy security are the
three largest problems facing the world
today in my opinion global warming may
cost the world on the order of 25 to 30
trillion dollars per year that's
trillion dollars per year by 2050 air
pollution already kills 4 to 7 million
people every year costing the world
about 20 to 25 trillion dollars per year
including that morbidities the illnesses
along with that hundreds of millions of
more ill people as well and then fossil
fuels are limited resources they will
run out over time and that will result
in prices rising and economic social and
political instability so we do need to
transition to something that's
sustainable and cleaned as soon as
possible and so that's kind of what I've
been working on is how to transition
cities towns states countries the whole
world in fact and all the way even down
to individual people's homes to 100%
clean renewable energy for everything to
try to solve all these problems
simultaneously man this is a whole mess
this is a whole mess that needs a whole
fix so ok so the last hundred years or
so especially we've been
ramping up our energy consumption and
we've been using fossil fuels to produce
our energy and it's helped a lot with
innovation helped allow a technology
growth and then now we're finally like
hey like this is unsustainable
so give us the numbers again in the
trillions of dollars of hurt and also in
people dying yeah well so in terms of
health air pollution health right now
four to seven million people die every
year from air pollution and this is in
cities that are very polluted like in
India and China most of them right now
are in developing countries it used to
be that the United States well back
actually during the Industrial
Revolution it was England and parts of
Europe that had the greatest air
pollution from human sources but then
that moved to the US and in the 50s and
60s especially Los Angeles was pretty
much the hotbed of air pollution and the
u.s. had huge problems throughout as did
other industrialized countries
especially after World War two and but
since then there have been strong
regulations in North America and Europe
in particular and that has reduced air
pollution significantly but there's
still about 65,000 premature air
pollution deaths in the United States
alone about 13,000 per year in
California but that pales in comparison
right now China over a million people
die every year from air pollution India
similar close to similar numbers how do
we know that they're dying from the air
pollution based on there's several ways
to find out there have been
epidemiological studies over the last
four to five decades that where you can
see from just looking at
hospitalizations how many people die on
a given day in fact correlated with air
pollution levels so you can actually
find a linear trend when air pollution
goes up more people die and are admitted
to hospitals and then they you can look
at the cause of death in Tuesday
cardiovascular disease respiratory
illness complications from asthma these
are the main ones kinds of deaths
although 20%
the mortalities now worldwide our
children under the age of five years old
and what happens a lot of them they're
just exposed to indoor cooking from and
heating using biomass or coal and a lot
of people in the world still cook with
coal in their homes or biomass just
burning dung or wood and these kids are
little that little bodies are exposed to
high levels of pollution and they become
weaker and so they might end up dying of
pneumonia but their immune system has
been a weakened due to this air
pollution it's an assault on their
bodies and in fact air pollution has
been correlated
well when if you have a heart attack
you're more likely to die of the heart
attack in polluted air than non polluted
air because these particles are just
invading your lungs the small ones get
deep into your lungs and they're just
invading your body they're assaulting in
any case there's strong evidence in
terms just just from correlations from
epi of DeMolay epidemiological studies
and looking at causes of death it's
they're usually respiratory
cardiovascular asthma and so anyway we
know that this is a sick even if
nificant problem and it's caused by
burning things by combustion and mostly
particles ends in pollution and even and
also ozone is another source which is a
gas in air pollution but these are
preventable causes of death I mean if we
stop Al if you stop the emissions of the
pollutants that create the particles or
create the yeah ozone we can eliminate
the that causes the deaths
immediately in fact those short-term
ones so I'm some of the longer-term ones
you you're still some people still dying
residually because of the build-up over
their lives but the way to eliminate
this problem is to transition to
electrify everything you and then
provide that electricity with clean
renewable energy and so really we that's
where we need to do in a large scale and
if we look at all the energy sectors the
people all the sectors that people use
energy and well there's electricity
there's transportation there's heating
and cooling of buildings and there's
industry high temperature industrial
processes so we really need to go
through each one of these
sectors and transition that to
electricity and then provide that
electricity with just clean renewable
energy namely wind and water and solar
power in our opinion and you've modeled
out what this looks like
currently with emissions and then you've
modeled out what it looks like with
wind/water/solar and the amount of
deaths the amount of money that's saved
I mean the just on the amount of
hospitalizations that were having
due to this there's gonna be so many new
jobs as well to stimulate the economy
with renewables there's lots of really
good and sustainability of our planet we
just won't live if we don't do this
right well we've calculated that if you
eliminate the air pollution mortalities
worldwide by transitioning you can
basically save three to five percent of
the world's gross domestic product on
top of that you create jobs we calculate
worldwide well first of all we we
developed energy plans for 139 out of
the 200 countries of the world for which
we had data for and also all 50 United
States we did separate energy plans and
now we just published 53 town and city
plans from North America and we found in
the world land though you've seen the
arse energy solution will show you guys
yeah that looks like because you weaken
it so the links in the bio to you guys
can go and visit it yeah and take a look
at it each individual country and state
also kind of collaborate with you and
say that we can do this or some of them
said they will we yeah we interact with
some but we really we develop these
plans consistently so we just basically
developed a methodology and didn't have
to actually consult them to come up with
the final plans but now that we have
final plans we're trying to consult with
some of these governments to try to
actually implement them I should just
mention that all these roadmaps the
country roadmaps the state roadmaps and
the city roadmaps are available with
easy access that the solutions project
org which is a nonprofit that I helped
co-found to actually take these energy
plans and try to educate the public and
policymakers about them but you can go
on there and find
the united states and click on each
state or find a city or find a country
of the world and click on that country
to up will pop an energy plan now
basically i we went through each of a
139 countries and developed plans to
transition each country to 100% clean
renewable energy so we calculated the
numbers what's the growth of energy
between now and 2050 based on population
increases and changes of energy use and
also accounting for increases in energy
efficiency and improvement under which
we call business as usual case which is
with basically fossil fuels and then we
transitioned each energy sector to clean
renewable energy well we lect Rifai to
each energy sector and then we then came
up with a number of wind turbine solar
panels etc to try to meet the annual
average power demand for each sector in
each country so when I say electrify for
example gasoline cars diesel cars trucks
buses we would Electrify those so we'd
have battery electric vehicles and for
long distance ships trains trucks and
aircraft hydrogen fuel cell battery
electric hybrids these are existing
technologies except for airplanes
they'll be a little more take more time
to actually commercialize the technology
there there is it like a hydrogen fuel
cell aircraft right now that seats four
people that can go 1500 kilometers and
the calculations that we've done it and
others have done indicate that you can
have a long-distance aircraft that will
be hydrogen fuel cell with some electric
electricity as well that could so you
can have these sustains long distance
flights that are based on hydrogen fuel
cells as well with you man have a larger
airplane due to the volume but the mass
is actually pretty similar so if the
surge in fuel cell is a sustainable form
of energy yes so the hydrogen in it's a
chemical reaction so the only product of
a hydrogen fuel cell is water vapor and
as opposed to jet fuel right now which
puts out
suit black carbon organic other organic
gases oxides of nitrogen sulfur as well
as huge amounts of water vapor much
larger than actually the water vapor
from the hydrogen fuel cell that would
replace it and so the current aircraft
create contrails which a lot of people
don't like because they crisscross the
sky and they affect climate as well and
so we would reduce we did still have
water vapor but there are no particles
coming from the hydrogen fills the fuel
cell aircraft so as a result there the
contrail sizes are much smaller and you
eliminate all the other emissions
associated with with fossil fuel
combustion but the hydrogen itself would
be created from electricity by passing
electricity through water and the
electricity would be wind water or solar
so this would be a very sustainable
system as well and just keep in mind I
mean the most rockets including the
space shuttles were propelled into space
with hydrogen but hydrogen combustion
around us rather than fuel cells but ok
so transportation we can cover them
it'll take the longest to get aircrafts
and some long distance ships as well but
everything else we can do I think pretty
rapidly and then industry we'd Electrify
that you just need high temperatures for
certain processes and we'd get those
high temperatures instead of burning
coal and gas and fuel oil we would get
there with electric arc furnaces
induction furnaces dielectric heaters
these are all existing technologies that
are already used in industry they just
need to expand them throughout the rest
of industry and then for heating for
your home we would eliminate gas their
heaters for air heating and water
heating and even eliminate electric
resistance heating we'd replace all
heating with heat pumps for both air and
water heating heat pumps are much more
efficient than other types of heating
what is that so heat pump so it moves
the air from either outside moves hot
there from outside to inside or it can
be run in Reverse where it takes cold
air from outside and moves it inside for
what it is outside is
and then you want to cool the inside
yeah so it even even if the air outside
is hot there still you can extract cold
some cold from outside air it just
becomes less efficient the hotter the
temperature is and but there and if you
get or if you're an in really extreme
climate where it's extremely hot like in
a desert or extremely cold like when
there's snow on the ground instead of
extracting the heat from the air you can
extract it from the ground so there's
there's what called what are called air
source heat pumps where you extract heat
from the air outside your house or
ground source heat pumps where you
extract the heat from the ground and it
used to be the ground source heat pumps
were really expensive because you'd have
to excavate your whole backyard and put
coils and try to track heat over this
reservoir in your backyard but now
there's a new technology where you can
just drill straight down and the this
company called dandelion
that they just have a technology that
you can drill stayed down extract the
heat and as so the cost has actually
come down so it's equivalent to the air
source heat pumps which are equivalent
to your gas heater now just to give an
example I recently built my own home and
it's been over a year now and I
electrified it so there's no gas on the
property and that saved me about six
thousand dollars of a hookup fee just to
then my utility wanted to charge me six
thousand dollars just to hook gas up
from the property line onto my property
and in addition to that there are pipes
that I avoided I didn't need gas pipes
and I never need fuel to pay for
anything we need to pay for a gas bill
so instead everything was electric that
solar on my roof batteries in the garage
and electric cars to replace gasoline
cars heat pumps for air heating air
conditioning and water heating these 1/4
the energy as gas heater for either and
instead of a gas stove in a electric
induction cooktop it's not an electric
resistant stove a lot of people don't
like electric resistance stoves because
they don't heat up very fast it's hard
to control the temperature but induction
cooktop stove
which is also electric it actually boils
water and half the time as gas does and
you can control the temperature really
easily and also you can touch the stove
and it's not even hot and so it has all
these advantages and it's about the same
cost as a gas stove but there's no fuel
you don't need gas fuel you just need
electricity and and then very efficient
lights so I basically have electric home
that during the day uses solar solar on
the rooftop powers pretty much
everything except if I need extra then I
there's the solar Ghost their solar
stored in the battery so the battery
turns on so at night for example the
battery will turn on and I'll use
battery electricity and only if the
battery runs out then do I need grid
electricity so over the last year or
over a one-year period ending last March
this meant this March I had no
electricity bill no gas bill natural gas
bill and no gasoline bill at all instead
I over generated my electricity for the
home by 20% in other words I produced
20% more electricity than I used for
everything including electric cars
heating cooling lights television
everything and that was sent back to the
grid the grid now they have these
Community Choice aggregation utilities
that will pay you for your electricity
at the time that it was generated which
could be there which is usually the peak
time of the day and so you get the peak
rate they sent me a check for five
hundred twenty eight dollars so they
paid no bills and got a check back and
this is a fully electric column so dr.
Jacobson how do you expect the rulers of
the world to stay in charge with all
this skatin the system and not profiting
off of energy well there's still ways
that utilities profit off the energy I
mean first of all they can go into the
energy business themselves because you
can like I have solar on my roof but a
utility can it's actually more the cost
for me is the upfront cost
I can't we just work together and create
our own energy system and get them get
rid of the middleman
that's what I'm saying you know that
it's just such a corrupt system and talk
to me about free energy suppression what
about the energy that's just out there
that they're just not you know that the
pyramids kind of grab into now did you
heard about these things are they
teaching you that at Stanford well I
think there's it's a good idea to be
able to control your own energy but it's
actually it there are some benefits of
HAP being on a grid too even if there
even if although created like I'm
controlling most of my own energy but
there are times of the year when I need
energy from the grid and and it's I
could get off the grid completely but
they you know it becomes an
asymptotically expensive probably I just
need a lot more batteries and more solar
to do that whereas if the grid were
cleaned up as well then I you know
everybody could be a hundred percent
clean renewable energy be at 100 percent
clean renewable energy so I think it's a
combination of having your own providing
your own power there's a benefit of
having rooftop solar for everybody to
generate ninety to ninety-five percent
of their own power but there's also a
benefit of having additional grid
electricity because you can actually do
grid electricity less expensively in
terms of the upfront costs because just
to give you an idea you know right now
that costs the cost of energy from let's
say natural gas is around six cents a
kilowatt hour six cents per kilowatt
hour for electricity from natural gas
whereas solar at the utility scale for
the big solar plant is on the order in
sunny places on the order of three to
four cents a kilowatt hour and wind is
even cheaper in the United States right
now it's on the order of two and a half
to three and a half cents at kilowatt
hours the cheapest form of new
electricity available so you can but a
rooftop solar might be twelve to fifteen
cents a kilowatt hour servers think so
it's actually more efficient for us to
stay on the grid because we can get it
from these places that have a better
concentration during certain hours for
example for wind it's just a better
place to get wind energy for solar
better place to get solar energy than it
is to get it on the rooftop so if I'd
get it via the grid it's actually more
efficient and more cheap but then again
I can also still get some solar
collection from my roof power in my
house as well and then you were
describing earlier the importance of all
of these different aspects of the house
from the heat pump to the solar roof to
all these energy efficiencies that
happen in the home and then that
decreases the cost significantly and
then you also have the credits that come
in as well and people can get paid for
that also the you know Ron mentioned
this as well there's a lot of this like
free energy suppression that's kind of
happened
what did Tesla discover what are we not
tapping into that is so invisible to us
but that could potentially enable us to
well maybe he's not at liberty to talk
about these things I would think that
would be a big secret this free energy
suppression you know do you have
children dr. Jacobson yeah you don't
have to elaborate on that question well
I mean I think there's there's enough
resource of known energy clean renewable
energy that we can power the entire
world so we don't and we wheat there's
the Sun the wind water you know these
are energy sources that are natural that
are replenishable that we can take
advantage I wanted to make one point
about the rooftop solar although it's
more expensive to install it's actually
because you can sell it back to the grid
at the peak time of the day at a very
high rate you know it's the it's really
what you're concerned about is the
bottom line like how much money do I pay
for it versus how much money do I
collect over my lifetime yeah and when
you do that analysis you'll find that
you know solar panels on your roof they
have a high upfront cost but they're
warrantied for like 30 years at least in
places in California in a lot of place
in the u.s. they're warrantied for 30
years they pay themselves off after
around seven years and so it's after
that it's free so
it doesn't matter if it's like what the
cost per kilowatt hour is it's really in
matters how much money you have in your
pocket at the end of the day and you're
going to have a lot of money at the end
in your pocket at the end of the day
because even though it's cost it costs a
lot to put it up you're getting money
paid back to you and the value of it
when you're using it is very high
whereas if you're buying grid
electricity you're paying a low price
for it but you're not getting any money
back so it does balance itself up no
respect but you know there's I think we
try to focus on well what are the known
solutions what are the what's a viable
way we can do it with you know almost
all existing technologies so we're not
looking for like some real surprise or
looking for or like some new technology
that because a lot of people really want
to hold out until there's some new great
technology that's going to solve all our
problems we don't want to do that we
want to focus we have to solve this
problem immediately we need 80% of the
problem to be solved within 12 years
from now and a hundred percent within by
2050 which is basically 32 years so but
80% by 2030 we cannot wait for a miracle
technology to solve this problem we have
to use the technologies that are viable
that we think can be improved but are
existing today and and we've run the
numbers and we think it's possible not
only to power every state and country
and city in the annual average but we've
also done what we call grid integration
studies where we look at time-dependent
matching power supply with demand every
30 seconds for several years and we've
done this in fact before because we
developed plans for 139 countries we
broke those countries into 20 world
regions and then did a study looking at
can we actually match power demand with
supply every 30 seconds for five years
in each of these 20 world regions we
found yes it's possible with storage so
the storage is another part of that
which includes batteries but also
what's called concentrated solar power
has storage associated with it pumped
hydro electric power or electric storage
existing hydroelectric reservoirs
they're basically big batteries you can
turn on and off to generate power but
also heat storage like in water and
rocks underground and cold storage and
water and ice and hydrogen is a form of
storage as well so by combining storage
with electricity production from
wind/water/solar and also when the
utilities give people incentives to use
electricity or not use it at certain
times of the day like for example you
know if what's the peak time of
electricity uses in the late afternoon
often in certain places well if you
actually make the electricity price high
at that time and make it lower at night
which they do right now then that shifts
people's demand for electricity tonight
so like for example I charge my electric
car you know after 11:00 p.m. because
that's when the electric no electricity
prices lowest and so that's when I would
charge it and so similarly a wastewater
treatment plan it doesn't need to run at
you know 405 in the afternoon it's gonna
run less expensively if it runs at night
or other hours so that's called demand
response and that's a way to who try to
match power demand with supply on the
grid that's cool
and so all right so we take this next
12-year period in this next 12 year
periods got to be like you said not just
waiting for a miracle technology it's
got to be what we already know wind
water or solar and actually implementing
those at high frequency and most
efficiency across the world for energy
consumption and then this sort of demand
that comes onto the grid work which
we're kind of we're kind of gamifying it
a little bit with the people but with
from the grid to the end-user by saying
that hey there's the most pull on the
grid at this time what if you waited and
closed your car and at the end of the
night instead of at what rate when you
came home but then they're like oh then
that
another thing to put on my to-do list
but then it costs you more money to do
that you're running your dishwasher at
11 p.m. instead of at 7 when you finish
dinner there's all these different types
of when do you do your laundry you want
to use your water for that so this is a
and maybe the smart appliances will just
do it for us at the time when the energy
sheepish
yeah actually that's the next step I
mean I have an irrigation system it's
run on a timer so you can run it on your
phone like when you want it when you
want it to run so you don't actually
have to go physically turn things on and
off dishwashers can be the same way I
mean right now I do actually manually
turn it on and off when I want to run it
when the electricity price is lowest but
I think that's a pretty trivial step to
make it automatic automatically run at
certain times and same with other things
I mean your my car charging I can do it
remotely - I don't have to actually
visit
plug the charger into my car right now
any time of the day and then set it to
charge yeah so this is something that's
becoming more and more automatic and
regular and if efficient and this is
this is good I mean but it's interesting
there are a lot of these devices though
like the dishwasher or even a washing
machine I mean they're actually not
using nearly as much energy electricity
as they used to new ones are very much
more energy efficient so that that's a
good part of a to energy efficiency
especially light bulbs I mean light
bulbs are just much more they use like
one-fiftieth the energy is they used to
the only D light bulbs so you can so it
I don't want to encourage anybody to
waste energy by just keeping your lights
on but it's just really beneficial I
mean the energy demand there's so much
lower with just new technologies yeah
and mostly across the board I want to
show some of the slides that you said
that we should also show
and let's discuss them as well
so the wws is wind/water/solar and that
solution is now being implemented thanks
to the our energy solution and your you
were talking about transportation as one
of the main aspects of this heating
cooling with water pumps or with heat
pumps and you kind of tapped you kind of
touched on a bunch of this as you went
along which is good rom what do we what
do we have next as well yeah so this is
types of storage systems we would use
you Longway see this yeah along with the
energy production so electricity storage
with concentrated solar power that CSP
in pumped hydro electric power existing
hydroelectric dams batteries heating
cooling storage and water the ice rocks
okay and then yeah I'm just extort just
so important along the way and to figure
out what is the best storage method
we're lithium ions pretty good right now
yeah they're they're excellent I mean
the only disadvantage is they're still
relatively expensive but actually you
know it's not that bad for your own home
because for example in my home I have a
bunch of solar panels that cost a lot
initially and there are two active
batteries doing you know solving most of
my problems and these two batteries
there are three thousand dollars each so
it's six thousand dollars you know but
that's on the order of maybe fifteen
percent of the solar PV cost and even
though you know it's not making me
totally energy independent of the grid
it's making me ninety to ninety-five
percent energy independent with the grid
and so for example here's here's an
example of seven days of energy use from
my home and from the summer and the
Green is solar production the light blue
is use in the home of some of that
sunlight to run things in the house
the dark blue well and then during the
day when I'm finished running things in
the house some of the electricity from
the solar goes to charge the batteries
at the bottom here shows the battery
being charged each day and then
discharging at night and then at night
the battery turns on and that's the dark
blue so you can see the RET well by the
way the red is the grid electricity you
can see hardly any grid electricity the
only times there's grid electricity
being used there's one in charging the
car there's two cars one takes faster
charge than the other but I don't have
enough in the battery to charge the car
so there I used green electricity but as
I mentioned before averaged over the
year i generated 20% more electricity
than i used yeah and got paid back back
so in this case you know so in this case
I'm you know I'm using something grid
but I'm generating more because all that
different the difference between that
green and the blue all goes back to the
grid yeah this case yeah how great is it
to generate more electricity than you
use no it feels really good because I'm
helping other people on the grid with
clean energy as well as providing clean
energy in my own home yep this is a
important graph because it actually
summarizes or 139 country plans so it
has the sum of all hundred 39 countries
what it indicates is that in 2012 there
are 12 trillion watts of power demanded
for end-use purposes in 139 countries of
the world these represent more than 99
percent of all the emissions worldwide
99% of the countries with a nine percent
of the emissions in 2050 that's expected
to grow to about 21 terra watts damn
it's a huge growth trillion watts
yeah trillion watts of power and that's
a terror terror watch yeah oh my god but
if we electrify everything that's so
much energy well that won't happen if we
go forward with the depopulation agenda
you know down to 500 million we should
be good to go no aren't they working on
that have you heard about that dr.
Jacobson man you talk about how the
fossil fuel industry you know kills a
million people a year you say
like it's a bad thing it's just it's
it's crazy that with seven and a half
billion people that were still
increasing our energy consumption so
much and we're just now really
transitioning to sustainable forms of
energy on massive scales because that's
that's a huge jump that's almost double
everyone's gonna want to live like an
American on the planet right well the
nice thing is though if we electrify
everything and provide that electricity
with clean renewable energy we can get
down to eight point six terawatts
without anybody changing their habits
and how how would we get down at eight
point six yeah 58% reduction so arts
Yuja our plan would be give you a 58%
reduction of power to me so let me start
with this one
energy self use twelve point six percent
of all the energy worldwide is used just
in line transport transport and refine
fossil fuels in uranium oh my god so if
we got a wind water Sun the sunlight
comes right to the panels wind comes
right to the turbines we don't need to
search for the underground we don't need
to dig drill and use energy for that so
that's 13% of energy is saved by
eliminating fossil fuels another 23%
reduction due to the fact that if fossil
fuels have a lot of embedded heat in
other words when you burn gasoline in
your car only seventeen to twenty
percent of the energy and the gasoline
goes to move your car the rest is just
waste heat that gets heats up the
inefficient it's it's twenty percent
yeah yeah it's 80 percent inefficient
that's so bad it's horrible but an
electric car eighty to eighty six
percent of the electricity in the car
goes to move the car and the rest is
waste heat so you actually if you
Electrify everything electrified
transportation you reduce your power
demand your end use power deven which by
about seventy five percent and so it's a
huge reduction in that sector but when
you average over all energy sectors you
actually get a lesser reduction of about
23% reduction of power demand just to
the efficiency of electricity busting to
keep
sweet 15 minutes i'ma thank you wrong
all right going to heat pumps there
every heat pump compared to a gas heater
it reduces your power demand by a factor
of four but average overall energy
sectors because heating is only in
cooling or only a portion of the total
energy use we can eliminate about 16
percent of energy just by going to heat
pumps for all heating and cooling of
buildings refrigeration and heating and
then we get another seven percent just
by pushing the limits of end-use energy
efficiency improvements and reducing
energy use beyond what's expected in the
business there's usual case this is this
is great and I love the the plan and I
love like let's let's definitely
highlight our energy solution I still
want to understand heat pumps better as
well because I want to understand how to
take a hot aired environment and find
cool air in there and pump it into the
into the building well oh well we'll
explain and learn more is there is there
a good point here as well that we should
well yeah this is how much land is
required to power basically the world
because this represents more than 99
percent of the energy with just wind
water and solar for all purposes and so
the bottom line is we would need for the
utility scale while for rooftop PV that
does not count as new land because it's
just going on the existing rooftops but
utility-scale photovoltaic and
concentrated solar power that's about
0.2 2% of the world's land and then
onshore wind is about 0.92 percent of
the land for the spacing between the
turbines but that spacing can be used
for multiple purposes such as
agricultural land so we only need one
percent of the land of the 139 countries
to power the whole world for everything
and keep in mind though that the current
fossil fuel industry like in the United
States there are in that's
wind/water/solar that's wind water and
solar for all energy sectors the fossil
fuel industry well in the United States
there are 1.7 million active oil and gas
wells and they're 2.3 million inactive
ones so they're four million total they
take up 1 to 2 percent of the United
States land area including the wells the
well pads
the storage facilities the roads
associated with these fineries they're
not even not even counting those we
haven't getting gun to them so just just
the gas and oil infrastructure in the US
it's 1 to 2% so this is 1% a little over
1% of the world's land for everything
for all energy and so we think it's
gonna take less land than the current
energy infrastructure
yeah I'm looking forward to continuing
to explore these calculations because
this is so crucial to do the transition
do we have another we have more slides
Ron well this was just the cost of
energy
so we're complicated but it's the cost
of energy resulting when you account for
the keeping the grid stable with
wind/water/solar the current fossil fuel
industry and the electric power sector
the direct cost of energy is 9 point 8
cents a kilowatt hour which is
relatively low but there's a fuel health
sorry there's a health cost associated
with fossil fuels due to air pollution
mortality yeah and then people get
hospitalized that's 12 point 7 cents a
kilowatt hour there's a 2050 climate
cost that'll be about 16 cents a
kilowatt hour so the total what we call
social cost of fossil fuels is 38 cents
again and you were listing the kilowatt
hour pricing it's already down to like
two and a half cents a kilowatt hour
well that's yeah that's solar that's for
the cost of me just this window just the
solar but not the whole keeping the grid
stable not the storage not the
transmission distribution and that would
be closer to 10 cents yes so in the wind
water solar case for the electric power
sector it's about nine point seven cents
a kilowatt hour overall when you account
for everything including the generation
the transmission distribution and the
storage and then there's no health costs
but there's no cost so but then there is
also a recycling cost with the
photovoltaics get better over time so
you'll want to recycle your solar panels
for better ones now wind turbines will
become more efficient and hydro yeah
keep in mind that these like wind
turbine solar panels they last on the
order of 25 30 years and then yeah they
would be recycled but that's included in
the cost of the energy
much better than a plastic water bottle
it's one I'm using you just toss it 30
right about 30 years yeah but the other
interesting thing is okay so this is
nine point seven cents per kilowatt-hour
but remember I mentioned that we use 50%
fewer kilowatt hours in the wind water
solar case because it's more efficient
so you use 50% less energy due to the
efficiencies that I mentioned before the
eliminating energy in the mining
transporting and refining follows the
efficiency of electricity for combustion
so they Matt it's really 1/8 the cost
this is 1/4 of that you need but because
we use 50% fewer kilowatt hours the
consumer is gonna pay 1/8 I was in the
fossil fuel system and then they can
sell back to the grid with energy
efficiencies as well well the other
benefits too what do we have a bran of
next now this was so we haven't really
talked about well what do people think
why is this no we're not a hundred
percent want a world with a hundred
percent renewable energy well I think
look at the second one only 66% of the
people in these this poll this is a poll
of 26,000 people in 13 13 countries and
only 66% believe climate change is a
global challenge so it's actually
pleasantly surprising though given this
number that 82% want a world with 100%
renewable energy average over all these
countries I mean who are the 18% of
people that don't understand that we
need it a world powered by renewable
energy to move forward well probably
some of them are people working in the
fossil fuel industry and those dirty rat
bastards earlier who are the people
suppressing the progress to renewables
there's a lot of money to be made that's
why there's a lot of suppression that's
going on yeah it's well there are a lot
of people who are either invested in the
current energy infrastructure or the
port it's just they're covering grain
because they've been fed lots of bad
things about renewable energy awesome so
we got a bunch of students committed to
hundred percent yes so nice thing is
they're actually even though our federal
government in the United States is not
doing a lot towards promoting 100%
clearing of letters you know
those numbers in order is like
Burlington Vermont leading the way
there's a good amount of California
representation on here which is good oh
yeah so the other achieve even more now
there was closer to 70 since I did the
slide a cities in the United States
towns and cities and it is he clipped
big ones and small ones like Atlanta
Georgia
San Francisco Madison Wisconsin San
Diego and but else a small country a
small cities and towns like Boone North
Carolina and Moab Utah
Beata Springs Louisiana have these
little guys come in chitlins which is
chitlins which Georgia in there yeah
these are like City Council's have voted
like some often unanimously
non-renewable to go to a hundred percent
renewables in there either city
operations or in trying to get the whole
town or city to go to a hundred percent
and then they're in some part of their
transition there what do we got what
else we got and then companies committed
this is good now the question is how
much are these cities and these
companies committed you know where
exactly are they in their process to
getting there yeah so there are over a
hundred and thirty companies worldwide
these are international companies and
most of the major companies in the world
have committed and like Google and Apple
claimed that they've already reached
that hundred percent target for all
their operations so all their data
centers all their buildings are now
theoretically according to them powered
with clean renewable hundred-percent
clean renewable electricity either they
bought wind farms or solar farms or like
in the case of Google also has solar up
spread over out over all the roofs and
can we plug it in kosha the browser have
you heard of them dr. Jacobson which
there's a browser that if you use they
donate their profits to renewable energy
to save trees or something like that are
you familiar with that no sorry
yeah
EKOS Yuri si o si hey okay I'll get in
touch with that for a spa I want to make
sure that that we do show that our
energy solution as well okay do we have
one we've another one Ron well some
reeved no this was just a summary of our
139 country plans about what that would
do create 24 million more jobs than are
lost these are long-term full-time jobs
required you know modest amounts of land
area eliminate 4 to 7 million air
pollution deaths per year slow than
reverse global warming you think we can
keep the grid stable with a hundred
percent clean renewable energy the wind
water solar energy cost is slightly less
just in terms of direct cost but the
energy post health and climate cost is
one fourth and when you account for the
fewer kilowatt hours use it's 1/8 the
cost of a fossil fuel system so this is
it's really like little downside to such
a transition yeah we were talking about
the beginning the immense amount of jobs
that are created the immense cost a drop
avoiding of death of hospitalizations
and the slow transition to renewables so
this is the you know this is your sight
the solutions project org and so on here
you can just browse by country so if you
click open the United States 100% United
States of America vision for transition
100% wind/water/solar residential
rooftop solar plants concentrating solar
plants or wind so you know you even show
construction job and operations jobs
over a 40-year period that are created
right the reduction in energy demand
health cost savings this is great it's
very relatable infographic it's really
well-designed money in your pocket that
you get to take and then the other good
thing is you can just go okay boom China
how about China yeah we that's we're
trying to make it easy I mean the
numbers are there's a lot lot more
information there detailed spreadsheets
that if anybody's interested can access
through one of the websites are I think
you're gonna post
we try to distill the information to
give you whether it's um what are some
of the important numbers and try to make
it easy to to understand because people
I mean most people are nothing I'd be
interested in details and I should point
out that these are you know the end use
the end plans that are developed in each
of these countries may not look like
this but this is like one way to get
there and really serves as motivation to
inspire countries policymakers as well
as individuals to say well this is
possible to do in each country let's see
if we can this is one way to do it so
let's see if we can try this way but
they might well find that there's
actually a more efficient way or a
different different pathway because of
some other limitation but we do believe
that there's at least one way in each
country to get there it seems like the
amount of countries that need to
actually visit the site and visit the
solutions project and reach out and
figure out how to collaborate it's huge
there's also the you know the
sustainable development goals that they
can collaborate with along the way
there's a couple of these sustainability
projects around the world that are going
on that if we're able to combine our our
minds and to the transition I think
you'll make it a much more seamless and
more efficient transit yeah well the
nice thing is there are lots of
nonprofits that are working together
with our solutions project to try to
implement a transition worldwide and
educate the public and their individuals
I mean from that public opinion poll I
mean 80 percent over 80 percent of the
people the world want to change so that
means a lot that so many people want to
change so that that's what's driving
these changes in individual cities and
towns and even in the companies as well
and this should only grow over time as
the need becomes more important as we're
seeing the impacts of climate change
getting worse and worse in particular
and people really especially in these
developing countries want to eliminate
this air pollution that's killing a
large portion of their populations yep I
like to ask especially 24 years now
professing in civil and environmental
engineering I like to ask professors
what one of their favorite parts is
about
expanding the minds of young people well
the nice thing is I mean I I teach them
climate I teach on air pollution I teach
on energy and then we have a program
called atmosphere energy where students
can understand the problems and the
solutions and so which really been
gratifying for me to see that we have
now on the order of four hundred
master's degree graduates and plus on
plus undergrads over the last fourteen
of these years because that's when we
started the program and they're all out
there
these students are out there now as
professionals working in energy or air
pollution or government agencies and
industry high-tech and it's really nice
to see that they are influencing they
are then influencing others around them
and helping to drive this transition as
well so this is really nice to see that
it's not just like it's not just a few
people I mean all these studies I talked
about here we have over 85 of our
students and also other researchers at
other universities we have contributed
to these studies so this is a large body
of people that have helped with this and
have really contributed and so it's
invented it as well so it gives me great
pride to know that a lot of our students
have done such great things and are now
working with others to help this
transition who's imagining mark just
sitting and just looking at all the
different paths that all the students
have taken and just seeing their impacts
and just that is a very beautiful part
of being a profession of enriching
people's minds and seeing what they do
with that we would have never thought of
once you teach they go off and do
something really interesting creative
with it like you said it takes a village
it's taking a massive village of people
from around the world to really crunch
all this together to make it happen
right so this has been a good
conversation about our transition 100%
renewable world now I've really wanted
to ask you because you said like earlier
you were just
that we can't just go with the miracle
technology but like just you know
figuring out how to you know get nuclear
fusion working seems so awesome of
course not tomorrow
but by 20 why do you bring up nuclear
all the time you know he didn't say
anything about nuclear technology in
this whole program not a thing why do
you have to bring that up
we don't need nuclear technology forget
about it let it go away don't bring it
up again the fusing of atoms is actually
huge for the potential did you know what
happened in Fukushima how's your fish
taste oh he's nice talking about
different technology than the fish huh
sorry alright nevermind I hate myself I
was born but well okay so Fusion is yeah
when you're when atoms come together and
release energy and that's you need
temperatures that are like in the middle
of the Sun I mean that's how the Sun
where the Sun works is basically through
nuclear fusion and I mean so it's not it
doesn't have all the same impacts it
doesn't have the same impact as fission
which is all nuclear reactors today so
it's not but it's it's something that
people have thought well maybe I'll be
available soon but projections are it
might not still be available for a
hundred years from now well in terms of
commercialized reactor that you know
that spins the atoms and Clyde's them in
the plasma form I'm trying to learn more
and more about this it's so hard to I
think you can well I don't know all the
details of what's the related research
but there's a difference between even
doing the research and commercializing
something and they totally because you
have to have the energy in be less than
the energy that you get yes and then
that has to consistently happen in a
safe way but I'm just I really want to
see the you know like you said
wind/water/solar these are the easy ones
we know they're safe we know how to do
them we've been doing them so let's do
the transition in that sense but also do
R&D into things like fusion along the
way as well would be something I'd be
very excited yeah people are not going
to start
stop doing R&D no matter what I say I'm
not gonna I won't be against it I just
think I think nuclear fission is a
problem because it not only I mean just
ignoring all the current things of
weapons proliferation meltdown risk
waste mining risk what do you do with
all the waste you challenge it's just
expensive and it takes long to put up so
you can be one nuclear all you want but
it takes takes between 11 and or sorry
10 to 19 years between planning and
operation of a single nuclear reactor
Yanis that costs like five times
totally big difference between fission
and fusion and definitely not as
interested in fission of course
ok so let's ask a couple questions
leading out first one do you think we're
alone in the cosmos well I think there
are many other planets in the solar
system not in our solar system planets
and other solar systems that are
reasonably close to the Sun not too
close not too far because like you know
the reason we have life on Earth is
because of the Goldilocks hypothesis
yeah that you know Mars is too cold or
Venus is too hot Mars is too cold earth
is just right the right distance so
there are probably other cases where
there's a planet the right distance from
the Sun in the solar system so there's I
think there's a good chance there's
probably life somewhere but I think
we'll never find it because all the
other solar systems are so far away that
just takes now we're not gonna find it
cuz it's a secret
thanks to you important what about do
you think we're in a simulation we're in
a simulation simulation so yes exactly I
don't think I could actually simulate
something so complicated as what we were
doing oh don't sell yourself short dr.
Jacob said you're a smart man
I never say there's not enough computer
time that's the problem
it's not that so you could actually
represent this with the physics of it
but I just a lot of energy a lot of math
the computer the computer processors are
just like just not even orders imagine
too many orders of magnitude too slow
soon years okay and then how about what
do you think the most beautiful thing in
the world well nature that's what adds
aspects I mean I I don't know just
there's just natural I just like nature
scenes of water running over rocks just
some things that are yeah Hector sq
trees growing plants beautiful flowers
yeah they pinned down they the most d
most beautiful thing but i've just seen
a lot of beautiful photographs today I
mean in terms of if I look at kind of
human-made things it's basically
certainly you know wind turbines solar
panels storage I mean I really like that
vision of powering something the earth
was something sustainable totally
likewise so that makes me feel good from
human human technologies yeah it's it's
almost like like you Drew and you guys
drew in your graphics that the fossil
fuel-burning is all like black and gray
and then when the water and solar is all
yellow and green and blue and and it's
like with the colors of Earth versus the
colors of death almost I can imagine
opening up one of the people's lungs
that are hospitalized and just being
like oh I have pictures of people's
lungs that have exposed to Los Angeles
air pollution in the 70s and it's like
smoking then I was smoking two packs of
cigarettes a day living in Los Angeles
yeah that's not cool and that's Los
Angeles it's not even the highly
polluted air cities of India and China
as well and I think they're doing a much
better job at cleaning it up the world
is moving in the right direction but we
need more people like you and more
people that are really trying to push us
in the in the form of renewable energy
for our world following that path mark
thank you so much yeah for joining us on
the show all right thank you for having
me understand what a pleasure yes and we
have some great links in the bio for you
to check out of course our energy
solution org write the solutions project
or the solutions project.org energies
and the links in the bio of course also
definitely do check out mark on Twitter
as well
MZ Jacobson on Twitter other links to
the atmospheric and energy program will
be down there and thanks everyone for
tuning in if you guys had a good time
definitely go share this content with
two other people let's get more and more
people talking about this go and write
about it go make a video about it so
don't just consume go create with it
join us on patreon help join the
community subscribe comment below we'd
love for year for you guys to join thank
you very much for tuning in and we'll
see you soon thank you
you
[Music]